we were just talking about romance and
consent
and marriage well marriage is getting an
overhaul
even as you get into marriage tiffany
is releasing their first ever men's
engagement rings so
you know you know typically for those
for those youths in the audience or
those people who have remained single
who have been living under a rock uh
when you get married what happens the
man
goes out and buys a ring and he proposes
marriage and the woman either accepts or
smacks him across the face and says no
and then she puts the ring on and then
you go get married
and then you can now now both parties
wear a wedding ring
though that wasn't always the case but
only the woman wears the engagement ring
well that's changing
i have had i'm so i've got to watch my
words here i've had some liberal friends
of mine
who are men engaged in this process
already
the men have worn us an engagement ring
because they say well if the woman wears
an engagement ring i should wear an
engagement ring too
because men and women are exactly the
same and completely indistinguishable so
of course whatever the woman does the
man has to do
whatever the man does the woman has to
do
okay i don't don't agree with that
approach don't agree with that
anthropology but i understand it
i understand the the reasoning there now
tiffany by coming out and saying here is
a men's engagement ring
they're taking this beyond a sort of
personal eccentricity and saying this
could be a new social tradition this
could be a new
aspect of proposing now
the the men's engagement rings it's
called the charles charles tiffany
and it includes emerald cut and round
diamonds up to five carats so i don't
you'd have to be pretty blingy here
who is this aimed at for the
straight fellas in the audience would
you wear the charles tiffany
engagement ring probably not right
but i don't think that i don't think
straight guys
are the audience here maybe some
feminist guys who think the men and
women have to do exactly the same thing
but i think it's
probably the reason for this is because
we have now from the supreme court
redefined marriage
to include not just monogamous
unions of husbands and wives but
also monogamous unions of the same sex
and so because of this if you know if
you're a
a man proposing to another man it's a
little who's going to do it which guy is
going to do it if you're now saying that
we are going to
redefine and expand the institution of
marriage
to include monogamous same-sex unions it
does raise a lot of questions
because sexual difference has always
been important to marriage it's always
been at the heart of marriage
even just to the basic question who's
going to propose the marriage and who's
going to accept the marriage
you have to try to work that sort of
thing out who gets the ring and do we
both get the ring
this is the one area i've pointed out on
the show and other conservatives have
pointed this out too
that the transgender ideology undermines
the homosexual rights ideology
and it undermines them because what gay
rights is very simple right we're born
this way
some boys like some boys like girls some
boys like boys and
there's really nothing we can do to
change that desire so society should be
more accepting of that
okay totally understand that and then
the transgender ideology comes in and
says actually there's no such thing as
boys or girls
and boys can become girls and girls can
become boys and everything's mutable
well that so much for the born this way
so much for the you can't change that so
much for the orientation that undercuts
it but there is one area where the two
link up
and that is on the redefinition of
marriage because
if if the argument for the redefinition
of marriage which you saw from the
supreme court is
that m plus w equals
m plus m then m has to equal w they have
to be indiscernible they have to be
exactly the same
and if that is the case then you're
going to see a lot more
social rituals such as the tiffany men's
engagement ring
you're going to see a social push
to take away that which is particular
and peculiar to men
and that which is particular to women
it's all going to have to be
the same but anyone who's ever been
in a marriage knows that it's not the
same i've got my cute little newborn kid
at home
could i nurture that kid no to a degree
i can i can play with him i can kiss him
i can say hey buddy you know and i can
have a nice time and i can even give him
a bottle every now and again
but i cannot provide for that baby what
sweet little elisa can provide for that
baby because sweet little alisa
is a lady and i am a grunting
knuckle-dragging brute
and the relationship of a baby of any
person to his mother
is different than the relationship to
his father and that's the way it is and
no amount of social engineering
is ever going to change that and
by the way for the for the gay guys in
the audience and ladies too
you know i don't want to exclude the
ladies here i have had
many of my gay friends tell me
that when they are in a relationship the
gender roles sort of come out there too
some guy is a little more like the
traditional guy some guy is a little
more like the traditional
girl in the way they interact and the
way they cook and the way they whatever
because those things come from nature
and then civilization
has developed them so of course there is
a social aspect to our sex just as there
is a biological aspect
but those two things are connected and
in this culture if we're going to just
deny that
entirely then things are going to go a
little bit kooky
throughout all aspects of the society
and and we can make ourselves feel
better and say this is all just it's all
just private michael what do you care
what do you care getting back to the
inciting incident here what do you care
if bill and melinda gates get divorced
i care quite a lot i care a lot if
anybody gets divorced
because that's people breaking their
contract and their pledge not just to
one another and not even just to god
i suppose that's between the parties
involved there
but they're breaking a pledge to me
they're breaking a pledge to society
they're breaking a pledge to their
children they're breaking a pledge
to the whole culture
that they will do their part and i know
it's a fallen world and these things
happen
but the question is here are we going to
encourage that sort of thing or are we
going to discourage that sort of thing
and the argument made not just by the
left but made by the right now as well
because the right has adopted the
ridiculous libertine redefinition of the
whole culture
that the left has foisted upon us this
is by the way the topic of my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now by the
way for pre-order
because we've adopted that language we
don't have any
philosophical tools at our disposal to
argue for the conservation of culture we
can't do it that's why we don't conserve
anything
that's one of the reasons why we don't
conserve anything hey stop right there
you before you go need to ring that bell
i know what you're thinking michael
michael
the decision of whether or not to ring
that bell it's a private decision
that i should make and me alone no it's
public buddy
it's public because we put these videos
out and then you might not get the
notifications
so you've got to do it i'm telling you
go ring that bell subscribe
like we'll see you next time
[Music]
you